what's your favorite opening
or what what openings do you like there
was an opening that
got me back into chess when I was 15. I
quit for like three years and I went to
my friend's house and he had a book
by Lars gandorf a Danish Grandmaster
called the Karo Khan defense which is
C6 do you want white to do you want
black do you want to show them the
opening this is the opening that's
Horicon defense so you play E4 I play C6
I have I have to play Black that's it
yeah absolutely and we developed from
here
what counts as a opening okay but the
development does the development matter
yeah so from here the development goes
into the variations of the Karo Khan so
this is the Karo Khan like you can be in
a city but then you can be in
neighborhoods so that's a very
non-dramatic okay uh
two Pawns in the center so that's called
The Briar variation so which what's a
good thing for me two two squares yeah
if you can put two Pawns in the center
yeah you should and then um so that's a
good thing yes and then I will go here
and now you have to decide what you're
gonna do with
your center point you can push take or
defend it
and uh push take or defend right yeah uh
what would you suggest take is the the
worst take is just stable so we just
trade but pushing is considered the best
advancing and taking my space away from
me
so I think Alpha zero or stockfish would
probably always push push and now
there's something called like the main
line or the sideline main line is what's
the most popular played at all levels
which is moving the bishop here I've
played this a lot but for beginners this
is an intermediate player's uh this is
why I love this opening so much on move
three black already has a plus score
which is
crazy like it's not supposed to happen
and there's this very tricky second most
popular move which is undermining your
Center trying to get you to take my free
Pawn but destabilize and leave both of
them kind of hanging and uh is that why
the the plus score
is because you're susceptible to the
destabil destabilization yes because
people at 99 of the rating ladder do not
understand how to deal with what's
coming basically they don't know how to
deal with a structural attack
so would uh would stockfish try to
defend the pawn here and keep no it
would take the pawn and tell you to go
[ __ ] yourself oh
because I am 3400 right I would take the
pawn and be like I win it back
and even if you did you would suffer it
would make you win it back in the most
annoying way it would make you tie your
shoes together and
so I uh like as stockfish I would taste
yes that's the best move but not at 99
of the rating ladder which is funny
interesting
um but you like to play this
I play this against GMS I play both I
move my Bishop I push it and you know
what are the different ways it evolves
like then the rest doesn't matter so
this is just like a pawn structure thing
uh yeah and I mean it how deep are most
openings
so it's anywhere from like two moves to
like 10 moves kind of thing yeah you can
be out of theory very very quickly to
move two move three like basically on
your own you have a general idea but you
don't remember games I mean I I know
Karo Khan games from start to finish
because I've played it since 2011. so
you know all the different branches that
goes without down yeah I I think I know
every opening in chess basically I think
most most title players know every
opening but we don't know we can't play
it competitively because we would be but
what are some of the weirder openings
that um
like slightly sub-optimal but might be
explored
like Magnus might play them just to [ __ ]
with the opponent he played something
recently actually uh against this German
Prodigy Vincent kymer which was um a
specific move order in a very popular
opening so it was basically a position
that had been reached thousands of times
but the move order Magnus chose with
white was played maybe
0.05 percent of the time which is crazy
thousands of games and it's supposed to
be not good meaning it allows black to
equalize because that's what black is
going for
it's not winning the game but equalizing
because you go second the magnet says I
don't care about equalizing I just want
a position I don't want my opponent to
know the answers to the test
and that's so interesting yeah because
also [ __ ] you psychologically it throws
you off and just always keep you on your
toes he's in a weird position but he
also has the advantage of being able to
intimidate
I wonder how many people
um
how much is that a roll of it like being
scared of the other person that's usual
I think I think some of the top guys
would deny it but
you know when you're in the seventh hour
and you're playing Magnus it's a very
different feeling than some of the other
when Magnus is messing around in the
opening it's very different than another
person messing around in the opening
you're just kind of like
expect to for something to be there